pop
[Musique]
et
cinq films de claude chabrol en fait de
stéphane audran depuis deux saisons
l'une des nouvelles grandes vedettes du
cinéma français ces cinq films sont les
biches la femme infidèle le boucher
la rupture est juste avant la nuit
[Musique]
or stéphane audran et aussi à la ville
madame claude chabrol
c'est à ce couple du 6 mai n'a que nous
rendons visite aujourd'hui c'est bien
tranquille moi je suis très heureux
j'étais vraiment très heureux non mon
rêve ce soit de ne rien [ __ ] un faux
pas vous mais moi aussi
stéphane audran si vous n'aviez pas été
la femme de claude chabrol
pensez-vous que vous auriez la situation
de comédienne la situation de vedettes
que vous avez aujourd'hui je crois pas
parce que vous savez moi quand j'ai
connu il ya dix ans je faisais pas grand
chose et ensuite quand j'ai commencé à
travailler avec lui je n'ai pas
travaillé beaucoup en dehors
j'ai l'impression que s'il n'avait pas
fait travailler je me demande qui aurait
pu avoir l'idée de faire ça vous a pas
posé un problème vous actrice déposé
metteur en scène ce qu'on vend pas on
est à l'aise et non pas de ce point de
vue là aucun truc comédienne qui ne
travaillent pas beaucoup aidé et d'avoir
épousé un metteur en scène qui était
déjà célèbre faire la bonne affaire
je peux vous dire que quand j'ai connu
en avait parfois pour moi c'est sûr 1
d'abord ça m'a permis de vivre et puis
et puis c'est un garçon charmant
j'ai fait une bonne affaire et vous en
avez fait une vedette mais ça c'est très
commode tant qu'affaire de faire tourner
sa femme autant qu'elles rapportent de
l'argent vous voyez parce que c'est même
plus facile pour faire les films parce
que si
maintenant c'est vraiment facile et d'un
maintien g1j un film avec un beau rôle
pour steph et bien le film monte tout de
suite pour réécoute pas allé sans et les
1000 les producteurs et distributeurs la
voit d'un bon oeil cette agréable au
mieux ça que dans le temps où je me
souviens de type qui mise et écoutez je
mets offerts faire un film et ne me
parlez pas de votre femme
alors c'était toujours d'anvers nord
voilà j'ai envoyé paître quand même
parce que c'était c'était pas du tout le
fait qu'ils voulaient pas l'utiliser
c'est de la façon dont il présentait la
source je vais vraiment l'air de trade
une pestiférée elle n'avait pas parié
avant vous conservez peut-être moi je
sais pas j'ai vedette ou non je sais que
maintenant quand claude propose on est
court plus de mes cousines ont fait plus
le détour
on est souvent bien content je suis dans
une distribution alors qu'avant cette
vue contraire on se sent ça va bien je
suis bien contente
est-ce que c'est facile une actrice
est-ce que c'est facile à moi de vivre
avec chabrol moi c'est très facile parce
que chabrol est très facile à vivre est
légèrement il est drôle et il est pas
bête il ne parle pas uniquement de son
métier parce que c'était beaucoup de
choses il me laisse tranquille
oui et en même temps il ya une grande
emprise vous comprenez intellectuelle
tout ça ça suffit alors moi je trouve
que c'est pas du tout handicap c'est
bien pour moi en situation de sujétion
vouliez un petit peu parce qu'il est
très absorbant parce qu'il est très très
il ya une personnalité énorme comme ça
qui vous tombe dessus
si vous propose un sujet qui ne soit pas
de chabrol et que chabrol est un sujet
pour vous au même moment lequel
choisissez vous parce que si je dis je
choisi notre chaban n'y va pas être
content 1
et si je dis je choisisse and roll ça va
vraiment vraiment pas être bon pour ma
carrière rôle c'est difficile
vous pensez à votre carrière ainsi peut
pas assez indien où la gouverner votre
carrière
cherchez vous avez un but je crois pas
tellement
est-ce vous qui vous occupez de la
carrière de votre femme or la 4e femme
un nom et elle a un agent comme on dit
ce mouvement avait tout le temps et
l'argent qu'elles gagnent pas que
l'actrice est l'homme elle mais je le
garde à ne vais pas dans le foyer si nos
noms alors là il ya un problème il
séduit mon souhait regret j'essaie de
mon soutien à feu vert c'est un jeu
entre nous je trouve toujours des
combines polluants soutirer mais ça ne
marche pas armand c'est difficile chez
oui j'ai vraiment puisé hamas trop
souvent à mains parce que tout est bon
de dire que j'ai des fois vous savez on
prête pas attention mais traque de faire
un chèque
et pourquoi êtes vous devenue comédienne
mais je suis devenue comédienne
pour m'amuser j'ai un copain qui m'a dit
on va chier des cours d'art dramatique
là comme ça c'est bien
j'y suis allé et j'ai suivi parce que
moi je faisais mes études puis je
m'amusais pas beaucoup que ce soit a
indiqué m
ces bons d'air vous pensiez vous étiez
doué au début oui au début je me
trouverais formidable j'étais sûr que
j'étais foutu bling mais finalement
rapidement je suis rendu compte que tu
es du tout été dur pour moi vous savez
c'était dur pour dire des textes c'était
dur pour marcher pour bouger et j'étais
pas la seule la fin c'est ça je crois
parce que j'ai pas tellement une
proposition et ensuite
ensuite il ya un professeur m'a donné un
rouge avait six phrases à dire dans
l'existant rata et puis après j'ai fait
pas grand chose j'ai fait des petites
tournées dans le sud-ouest un cadre au
mac
là c'était vraiment mauvais là j'étais
pas vraiment très bonne
il avait un petit peu le cafard mais je
sais pas pourquoi je continuais ne
pouvait pas envisager de faire votre
mission vous arrivez à gagner votre vie
non pas tellement non comme ça parce que
j'étais mariée à un acteur qui
travaillent augurer un peu hautain et
puis ma mère me donner un peu d'argent
au cinéma j'essayais de voir les
metteurs en scène j'essayais de me
présenter dans les productions
impossible de voir le metteur en scène
gérard blain avait tourné le mot serge
avec chabrol je dis vraiment il faut que
tu me fasses connaître ce type qui a
l'air marrant vous dire quand même parce
qu'il est marrant par wimbée beau père
travaille un oui parce qu'il était
marrant alors j'ai cherché à avoir un
rôle dans les coudes
[Musique]